Zubereitung Titel eingeblendet wir also
sein Gericht
wie bekommt man Anmachsprüche vorgelesen
von Hallo
[Musik]
das gut weil ich denke mal
Solaranlagen Bügeleisen gekauft du musst
mich hier wie du Spruch
[Musik]
du kannst ja mich gibt's so viele Kurven
und ich ohne Bremse
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe kein Auto
[Musik]
keine Familie ich bin Safi Urlaub und du
darfst nicht meinen Namen tragen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nee na ja sagen wir jetzt ab jetzt lass
der Bus
deine Anwesenheit heute Nacht im
Schlafzimmer
Entschuldigung
Entschuldigung kann es sein dass ich in
einer verliebt war
[Musik]
ich bin kein Mann für eine Nacht aber
ein bis zwei Stunden hätte ich schon
Zeit
lieber nur halbe Stunde
ich bin nicht wirklich
[Musik]
ich bin so betrunken dass du gar nicht
mal schlecht aussiehst
das denken sich alle Leute bei dir im
Club
mit einem großen noch eine große
Verantwortung
hast du schon mal einen echten
Feuerwehrschlauch in der Hand gehabt
ich liebe jeden Muskel in deinem Körper
besonders meinen
hamena
gedauert
ich bin Umzugshelfer soll ich dir beim
Ausziehen helfen
das kann ich selber weil ich zeige so
eine Finger hab Hände und Füße
oder warum bist du so heiß
ich bin immer heiß
zurück ich weiß nicht wie groß er wird
nur
zurück
ja bis dann mein Doppelkinn weg ist
die Sonate
Bescheid geben dass ich heute bei dir
schlafe
hast du Lust zu angeln ich würde gerne
meinen Köder in deinen Teich werfen
der mir in die Gebärmutter
magst du Blumen ich habe Samen
kinderlack
ich wär sehr gern der Grund für deine
heutige schlaflose Nacht
man sagt immer die größten Schätze
liegen unter der Erde aber ich kann dich
ja nicht einfach eingraben
war das
gerade ein Erdbeben oder bringst du
meine Welt so zum beben
Camelia zwinkert nicht
oder hat er sich aber selber krank hatte
der kann auch von dir ne
Sandra
[Musik]
ich fliege auf dich kann ich auf der
London Eye
[Musik]
[Applaus]